okay hi everyone
well this is the beginning of a new
series that i'm
looking at about uh history of science
and technology q
a about history of science and
technology and
um i'll talk about anything i know about
uh it um
i haven't quite figured out what my
principles are going to be about talking
about
living people and what kinds of things i
can say and can't say
but um i'm um
um i'm going to
kind of let's see the the i'm going to
talk about a bunch of different things
now actually one
question that had um
come up in an earlier live stream today
about
um software design was a question about
the history of
lisp maybe i can start by talking a
little bit about that i'll talk a little
bit about the history of programming
languages in general
and the history of lisp in particular
so when did digital computers come into
existence well
you know things like the eniac were
around 1946 i guess
we talk about the pre-history of those
things that's sort of a separate topic
but um when there started to be
computers
they started to have these sort of
well-defined modules
of operations that they could do and
they're slowly started to be stored
program computers where you could like
specify the program
but the program was very much like make
the addition
uh you know module do this make for this
module do that
it was very direct you know instructions
to the different pieces of the machine
and then they're slowly started to be in
the in the 1950s there started to be
kind of a a let's write
kind of uh what was originally called
symbolic languages
i think um but they were really
languages that that
tried to not go all the way down to the
details of
which particular uh storage location in
the machine
should do which particular thing and the
two very early languages were fortran
and cobol
um both around 1956 to 58 i think
um one of the things that people were
very obsessed with at that time was
what would like the grammar of the
language be like
strangely in 1956 there was sort of a um
a convergence of two completely
different threads of intellectual
development
and i i'm just amazed that they happened
in the same year
um one of them was the uh
this thing now called bacchus nowa form
which is this kind of recursive
specification
of the structure of a computer language
and the other was
uh chomsky's generative linguistics
generative uh
grammar approach to natural language so
just
talking about both of those for a moment
the question is
if you're going to say what is a
possible
uh word what is a possible thing that
can appear in a computer language
it might be something like oh we've got
expressions of the form blah
plus blah and the blahs can in turn be
parenthesis blah plus parenthesis you
know blah times blah
and what we're saying is when i say blah
that blah
is sort of an a recursively defined
thing because the blah
could itself be an addition thing a
multiplication thing a thing with
parentheses
so you can write that all out as a kind
of a a description a kind of
a specification of the grammar of the
language
by saying blah can be blah blah blah or
paren blah paren or blah times blah
and then at the bottom you can say or
blah can be like a number or something
and and so that's a sort of recursive
definition of
uh that can be used to specify the
syntax of a computer language
and that's what bacchus now a form uh
was about for computer languages
uh strangely at the same time uh
uh noam chomsky had come up with this
generative grammar idea
um i think that had had some precursors
uh
in um see this is gonna be one of these
problems with this history um
oh my gosh noam chomsky's kind of
undergraduate advisor at university of
pennsylvania i lost the name sorry
um the uh um
but there have been some precursors uh
to that but but
for many many years uh people had um
um uh the um
uh had had kind of um uh had written
grammar books and so on but they hadn't
really been formalized like that
and there hadn't been the the idea that
there could be a procedure for like
generate all the sentences of such and
such a language
now actually as is often the case that
idea had had a precursor
there was a grammarian called panini who
did a grammar
of sanskrit i'm not quite sure when
maybe
maybe a few centuries bc um
and uh and it was even known to people
you know in in
antiquity in greek and latin there was a
decent level of knowledge of kind of
the structure of grammar as a formal
thing people like lucretius
commented on it as actually a possible
theory for how physics might work in the
first century a.d
lucretius was talking about how you know
the the world might be made up
of um uh of things much as
sentences are made up from words
according to a certain grammar
many cases 1956 these two different
lines of development converge there's a
question here do i do i know noam
chomsky personally i've certainly met
him
i've actually asked him about what
happened in 1956 i didn't get
a lot of clarity about um about that
uh from from him i i think that um uh
my impression was that he was aware of
the work that was going on
in computer languages i'm not sure how
aware the people in computer languages
were
of generative grammar so i i don't
really know what the what the historical
chain was there
um the um uh i think
that um um
uh the okay so we're we're back to the
the kind of um
the developments of of um computer
languages
uh fortran cobalt two early languages
which have survived um there were many
others that did not survive
um i think the um uh
both of those languages i think um uh
had a certain degree of well ibm was
sort of the dominant
uh computer company of the time um and
that was uh those languages
certainly had involvement with ibm but
um
people had um uh
that was sort of in the development of
practical computer languages that's like
you write this program and it actually
runs on the computers that exist at that
time
there was also the more theoretical
development that had come out of things
like turing machines
turing machines invented in 1936 lambda
calculus invented basically at the same
time
um the the idea of recursive functions
was actually a little bit older
um kurt gerdel had used general
recursive functions in his proof of
girdles theorem
in 1931 a recursive function is a
function where
you define the function in terms of
itself so you might define a factorial f
of n
is defined to be n uh times f of n minus
one so
f of n is defined in terms of another
instance of f it's the same idea as with
these recursive definitions of grammars
uh same same basic kind of concept um
but recursive functions were known to be
one of the possible basis for doing
computation
all of these different bases for
computation were known to be equivalent
that was already known by 1940-ish um
but then the question was would there be
a way in which
those kind of theoretical bases for
computation entered the world of
practical computers
and it really didn't happen very much
one of the big things that happened uh
heading towards 1960 was the creation of
algol 60.
algo was intended to be a a committee
made
you know the experts of the world will
come together and define the be all
end-all
language for um uh
for for computing and it was going to be
algol the algorithmic language
uh type thing algol 60 was uh for the
sort of 1960
edition of that um in the end algo
wasn't really implemented much
i'm not even sure there was ever a
complete algol that was made
but algo was very influential in terms
of defining
sort of what the typical programming
language might look like and in fact
basically most standard low-level
programming languages are very algol
like even today
but there was kind of a there were
sub-branches to that and i'll go
was very much a story of use this
bacchus now a form
to represent the the syntax of the
language and so on
and there was there was really an
emphasis on on sort of the syntactic
structure of the language and on on how
uh there was the idea of having
variables where you could uh you know
set a variable to something and that
would correspond to
actually setting putting a value in some
particular location in computer memory
where the particular location would be
decided by the compiler of the language
and so on and
the loader and such like but um
the uh uh by compiler i mean the the
program that that turned that
turned the sort of high-level fortran
code into
the actual machine code of the computer
on which it was going to run
but um one kind of outlier there were
two important outliers one outlier to
that story was
some the lisp language which was kind of
originally proposed
as a let's take the idea of recursive
functions
and try and see whether we can make a
practical language
along those lines and the person who who
proposed it was a chap called john
mccarthy
um and his original proposal i guess was
around 1959
um and in fact the the the idea
was let's take something quite formal
quite uh you know algol had also been
quite formal but algo was more
concentrated i would say on the syntax
than on the semantics of what was going
on although maybe a little unfair i
haven't read the algol standard in a
very very very long
time but in the case of what john
mccarthy was doing
the idea was this would be a thing that
sort of implemented recursive functions
well one of the questions was how should
he actually
set up the representation of recursive
functions and he was aware of alonzo
church's work from
1935 1936 then 1940 and so on on lambda
calculus
and that was uh uh and the way that he
chose to set up functions was sort of in
some imitation of lambda calculus
um actually he was also as i realized
only very very recently
also aware of moses sean finkel's work
on combinators
from 1920 um which had the notable
feature that it
it didn't have to deal with variables
see see one of the things and
let's not get into the too much of the
technical details of this but
it's sort of the bane of of a lot of
computing is you want to name a thing
you call it x but you use it
you you have this thing you've called it
x now you have another thing
and you independently name it and by the
way you happen to call it x
what happens and how do you scope
the names x and what they refer to and
that's a very
complicated issue that it's not clear it
wasn't clear when lambda calculus was
first invented
it wasn't clear you could ever untangle
that issue or whether
these names would get forever tangled up
and prevent you from
from proving useful mathematical
theorems and so on combinators
are much more difficult to understand
but and were invented before all of
these things
but had the feature that they don't
involve variables at all
they they just deliver data to the right
place by having the sort of
transformations of symbolic expressions
and they never have to name anything
well the good news is
that means you can prove all kinds of
theorems the bad news is us humans are
pretty lost in figuring out what's going
on
we don't have a way it's like if i were
uh talking about things in in
in language and i would just saying the
blah and the blood and the
blah blah blah blah blah et cetera and i
never fill in what blah means until the
very very very end
when it's like dog cat et cetera et
cetera they're going to be filled in for
those
those things it's very hard to
understand that without the kind of
intermediate sort of separately
understandable thing
but anyway john mccarthy i i recently
learned also was aware of um
uh of um uh
of of um uh of combinators and and sort
of
says it even in his paper i just found
this recently we could use combinators
but they would be very obscure
and so we're going to use this thing
that sort of modeled on lambda calculus
now what happened to lisp was uh at the
time there was sort of toy versions of
lists that started to be implemented but
fundamentally
it was really hard to implement on a on
the machines that existed in the early
1960s
those were primarily mainframe computers
that was sort of a
the the ibm 360 was the quintessential
mainframe computer
and it was kind of like the the um the
notion was they were big computers i
mean i
i used one it was a you know it was the
size of a room and it was in special air
conditioning and
usually i was i was very lucky i worked
at argonne national lab in the summer of
1977
and um uh it was a place where they
trusted the scientists so to speak and
even the kid scientists like me
to actually be in the room with the with
the mainframe computer so i actually got
to kind of uh
touch the machine so to speak um in most
other places it was just uh
you know only the the people behind the
scenes possibly even wearing white coats
uh would be touching the mainframe
computer and uh the the simple
users will be just putting card decks in
pigeon holes and somebody will be
taking them from the other side of the
pigeon holes and going and mysteriously
doing things on the computer and then
delivering the
the printed output back to the pigeon
hole so to speak but um
anyway so the the um but the ibm 360
and i think actually the the um there's
probably a precursor to the 360 maybe
801 if i remember correctly
i've forgotten that um famously had the
instructions
car and cutter which became actual uh
sort of language instructions and lisp
um
for um what are they they're they're
prepend and and rest i suppose in
wolfram language i think that's right
um the uh uh
but but so okay so anyway lisp
was kind of a um uh gosh there's so much
to say about this and it's hard to know
where to start
um it was sort of a good conceptual idea
it was uh hard to implement and it
didn't get efficiently implemented
really uh you know until quite modern
times
you know one of the things that's often
said by people who were involved with
lisp is
you know every uh uh they would say uh
thinking it to be well i don't know but
but uh
um you know every sufficiently
sophisticated programming language will
eventually recreate lisp
well welcome to the universal
computation that's sort of inevitable
um it's uh you know every every
sufficiently rich
uh computational environment will will
reflect
every other computational environment at
some level
but in any case the the um uh
characteristic of lisp was that it's
it's um the syntax going away from the
kind of obsession with syntax that had
uh was it was in lots of other languages
you know the original version of lisp
was just a bunch of parentheses nested
parentheses and things
not kind of functional notation of the
kind that we would normally use in math
or more from language or in
or in other or in programming languages
and so on um
and actually in john mccarthy's paper he
says well we're going to use this
s expression form that's just these
nasty parentheses for now
but there's an m expression form which
looks bizarrely similar to wolfram
language today
um that we'll get around to at some
point actually i
i i remember talking to him about that
and he said well yes
back in 1959 we thought we'd get around
to it very very soon
but i was talking to him sometime
probably in the
maybe 1990s or early 2000s and hadn't
gotten around to it yet by then
but any case the the um uh you know
lisp was kind of
promoted as the language of um
uh of artificial intelligence and in the
early 60s
uh was a time when there was just
tremendous enthusiasm for artificial
intelligence it was
it was like we've made computers pretty
soon they're going to be just like
brains
and we're going to be able to do every
intelligent thing that brains can do
and it was sort of interesting because
before that time before the i would say
that that that was a growing
sort of tide that that happened from the
mid 1950s up until the 1960s
like for example in 1956 there was a
sort of famous conference i was just
looking at the proceedings of it
actually
just a couple of days ago uh
interestingly enough uh it was
it was a conference in dartmouth
um 1956. the proceedings were edited by
claude shannon
and uh john mccarthy and it featured
marvin minsky and lots of other
uh sort of people from the early days i
think uh
michael raymond might have been in that
um a bunch of people from sort of the
early days
of uh of kind of thinking about um
theory of computation
and its application to to practice
but you know i think john mccarthy's
paper in that as i recall
was something about the inverses of
turing machines
um it's definitely not a kind of uh sort
of a practical computer language thing
and a lot of what's in there is
is kind of can we make a touring machine
a touring machine really a touring
machine
that um is somehow intelligent now
now or somehow has artificial
intelligence now a part of the segway to
that
had been the work by will pitts and
warren mcculloch
um in the 1940s on early neural nets
i mean they had kind of that was a time
when um oh i don't know
psychiatry was sort of the top field in
some sense the
really expanding field at the time
warren mcculloch was a psychiatrist
based in the chicago area uh walter
pitts was a young
kind of uh funky uh background fellow
who sort of wound up at the um at the
university of chicago as sort of a
a math and what today would be a sort of
computing
prodigy type um but
those two kind of warren mcculloch kind
of wanted to find this sort of
uh mathematical idealization of the way
that brains work and it was known it had
been known since
um uh romani cajal in around 1900
that there were neurons in brains they'd
done the microscopy and drawn these
beautiful pictures
of all these elaborate neurons that that
looked awfully like the wires that
people saw inside computers
um back in in in the 1940s and so on
and so there was the obvious question
you know could we make a kind of
wires like model of how brains work we
you know it was known by that time that
um i was it known for a long time
actually that um
uh that brains were sort of electrical
in their operation i mean it was known
even
even when volta was discovering you know
the the you can make a a frog's leg
kick um by connecting it to uh some
electrochemical battery type thing
um it was it had been clear that there
were kind of electrical signals involved
with nerves
so so anyway but but back in 1943
i think um uh walter pitts and warren
mcculloch
um wrote this paper about about neural
networks
that was sort of an attempt to idealize
away from the the details of neurons and
come up with something more
mathematical so to speak and one of
their sort of key ideas was
and let's see if we can show its
equivalent to turing machines
because then they had the idea if it's
equivalent to turing machines then it's
equivalent to lambda calculus it can
compute all these things and so on
so that was kind of a connection between
kind of the
the world of um uh the world of sort of
intelligence and brains into this kind
of
and it might be like a turing machine
type thing and that that led to
particularly at that time there's a lot
of work on finite automata
um just uh things where you have a
finite number of states and you say you
know it's like a
an elevator or something which might
have a state that says the elevator is
going up the elevator is going down
a button is pressed that changes the
state that does et cetera et cetera et
cetera
just these state transitions and so on
the theory of finance automata was kind
of big in the 1950s and
and got more or less figured out in the
1950s um and i think that the um
uh the thing that um uh entering
machines are sort of
the they're not finite they have tapes
that can be infinitely long
so they can store an infinite amount of
information and that kind of brings them
into another class of computation
but sort of the first idea was could
brains be kind of modeled like finite
automata
and then there was okay then what about
turing machines and so on
but um in any case the the this sort of
all converged
i think into this kind of can we do
artificial intelligence
uh by the way it also was the case that
that often people would refer to
uh computers as sort of things like
giant electronic brains
that was the kind of 1950s style you
know popular name for what a computer
is it's it's like a giant electronic
brain
and and there have been things which
were sort of very very toy examples of
artificial intelligence i think there
was a
a trap called gray walter who um
uh who made this turtle-like thing was
sort of a hemispherical turtle
was made for the world's fair in the
mid-1950s i think
new york world's fair maybe um and it
was a
it was a thing that had sort of motor
inside it would run around on the ground
and it would follow white lines on the
ground and so on
using photo photo diodes probably um
and it was kind of the original model
that led to things like the logo turtle
and the
nowadays the scratch cat and things like
this um
but it was this kind of turtle running
around on the ground and it actually
at the time it was pretty famous turtle
it made the cover of time magazine and
all those sorts of things and it was
like well every home have one of these
uh
you know robotic turtles running around
well actually lots of homes now have
robotic vacuum cleaners which look
strange similar to that
but uh came through you know a long
series of
of technology development to get to that
point but anyway so
so there was this idea that you know
artificial intelligence
giant electronic brains easy to do going
to be on their way real soon now
and that was that was an idea that um
and then there were sort of questions
about
well how would you get to that point how
would you know what would be the
what would be the immediate things you
were trying to do there was things like
object recognition
okay so visual object recognition um
people had
uh you know you could have a small array
of pixels
and there was a question of you know
could you could you recognize
things by just looking at these pictures
with a smaller array of pixels
there's a chat called frank rosenblatt
cornell who invented these things called
perceptrons
which were kind of a way of using what
amounted to
kind of uh sort of threshold linear
algebra
to be able to say you take the inputs
from all those all those pixels
and you compute this function and then
you say does
it is this function closer to this or
closer to that uh if it's closer to this
then it's a cat if it's closer to that
then it's a dog
um and so that was that was an early
kind of um
uh approach to sort of a pseudo-ai thing
now
you know things weren't went kind of
wrong because you know you would do very
very simple training of perceptrons and
the famous example with recognizing
tanks um pictures of tanks
and it was like oh well we're training
it on this set of tanks and this set of
pictures
and so on it turned out really in the
end the perceptron was just recognizing
whether the picture was taken at the day
or night and it wasn't really
recognizing much about tanks at all but
it wasn't obvious that was what was
going on because it was just like
well we got this training set and this
was in the 1950s so
maybe in 1960 but by then um so it was
it was kind of a
um you know that that was some uh it's
interesting the same issues come up in
machine learning today
nothing really changes uh by the way at
that same time people were starting to
use two-dimensional cellular automata
to do things like optical character
recognition that was already starting
in the 1950s um and and subsequently
neural nets got used for that was very
early application of neural nets
but in any case the um uh let's see
where was i we were talking about ai
you know other applications of ai there
were things like
um well one was was things like medical
diagnosis
you know there are all these different
parts for um you know
you ask this question could it be this
could it be that it's kind of like the
20 questions version
of medical diagnosis you know which of
the 100 000 things in the icd-10 you
know medical diagnosis
codes list do you actually have well do
you have a sore throat do you have this
do you have that
you know make those choices um that
kind of uh that that question
well there were there were that that led
to a system called dendral which was
kind of a tree
a tree searching system and somehow that
related
to also early studies of theorem proving
um it's related but i don't yeah okay so
i mean in theorem proving
what you're doing is you're saying i
have these axioms and i can make these
moves to change mathematical expressions
which sequence of moves should i make to
get to this
answer that's kind of the what you need
to do to sort of prove a theorem in this
kind of idealized way
strangely it's also very similar to the
question of what do i need to do to
synthesize a particular chemical
if i have certain chemical reactions
that i can can do and even the 1960s
people were exploring i think um uh e.j
corey at harvard was already exploring
uh famous for retrosynthesis and other
such things was already exploring
these ideas about um uh kind of um
the um uh uh
using uh sort of theorem proving-ish
methods to chemical
uh synthesis i think back in i think it
was a big effort at stanford i think
around dendrol
i think joshua lederberg was involved
with that i i
yeah i mean i remember talking to him
about it many many many years later
um and asking him why did nobody follow
up you know why wasn't there a big
effort in sort of automated medical
diagnosis he said he didn't really know
should have been there wasn't um
as um joshua lutterberg was a
microbiologist
uh latterly at uh rockefeller university
um and i think uh i was famous um one of
the things he was
perhaps famous for to some people is he
was the person who who convinced people
that when the apollo astronauts came
back for the move from the moon
they should be in quarantine feels a bit
like today because
just think about what moon bugs they
might have brought back we didn't know
so so in any case the the thing that um
uh you know so back in early 60s these
various initiatives
of um uh sort of the sort of treeing out
of things and theorem proving
maybe a medical diagnosis that was one
kind of approach
there was also kind of the idea uh that
um uh you know if you wanted to
understand
ai you could sort of look at these
simplified situations you could look at
this kind of
world of blocks and you could say if you
just had to figure out
how could you put this block on top of
this block and how could you plan what
to do
how would you how would you do that it
later turned out that that wasn't
that was a fine model for understanding
sort of mathematical style
optimization problems it wasn't a
particularly good model for
understanding the things that nowadays
we think of as being the sort of
mushy you know aish kinds of judgment
type type uh things another direction
was in
uh natural language processing and in
particular there was this great interest
in language translation for a very
bizarre reason i mean this was the
you know the height of the cold war 1962
you know the cuban missile crisis
all these kinds of things and there was
a there was this idea that you know
there would be these high-level talks
between the soviets and the americans or
whatever
and um you know one of the weak links
that was thought was the interpreters
who were
you know translating russian to english
whatever else you know what if an
interpreter what if one
side said you know we will allow no
missiles in cuba
and the interpreter mistranslated that
to uh
you know uh the beaches in cuba are
wonderful
or something um the uh you know that
might start world war three
and so the bright idea was had by the
then it was probably
probably opera at that time as opposed
to darpa um
uh the parts of the defense department
involved with
uh um advanced research projects and so
on
that um uh i think they were already
existed at that time
yeah um that um uh that gosh
the way to avoid human error would be to
have a machine do that translation
let's really push machine translation
now of course
we now know machine translation was a
lot harder than people expected
um but that was another big push in the
1960s and and really this whole
you know a whole collection of things
sort of automated mathematics automated
language translation
all these kinds of things they all kind
of they all kind of were
the big story of ai in the 1960s and
underneath the more symbolic of these
the ones that involved
things like making deductions about
things and so on
lisp was the thing that was kind of the
the story of how you should do that
well then we come to the late 1970s
uh when i started working on uh symbolic
computation
and trying to build well precursors of
wolfram language i built this thing
called snp
starting in 1979. i did the shocking
thing i built smp using the c
programming language
not using lisp why didn't i use lisp
because i didn't really
need to lisp was at that time not well
implemented it didn't run
fast it was had all kinds of problems
with memory management
and i knew that the basic operations i
needed i could implement quite easily
and i could implement them in sort of
the form that i wanted which as it turns
out
is this idea of transformation rules of
symbolic patterns
that transform symbolic expressions
which has for the last 40 years been an
extremely powerful paradigm
that we've been able to use in welfare
language that isn't really the paradigm
of things like lisp
it's a little bit similar and you could
obviously write
a pattern transformation system in lisp
but it wasn't what
lisp naturally did and it made a lot
more sense for
that to be something that was written
directly in c
which was at that time a new sort of
low-level program implementation
language that had been built basically
for the creation of the unix operating
system
at bell labs but anyway so so that was
probably that was i must have run into
john mccarthy
for the first time probably around the
time i was working on smp
and he did not like the fact that i
wasn't using lisp
you know this was an ai-ish application
and it wasn't using lisp
and i think that that led to a kind of a
i would say a a rather negative vibe
um with john mccarthy i mean i can uh oh
gosh
i remember this must have been was it
[Music]
1981 maybe
1982 i can't remember i was i was at
caltech
um kind of being a a young physicist
there
and um i was um
i can't remember exactly what the
precise situation was but anyway i was
i was like i'm gonna eventually i ended
up moving from caltech for
for reasons having to do with the first
company that i started and all kind of
intellectual property issues and so on
but anyway i was
i was sort of uh uh on a job search type
thing
and i had i had decided stanford was was
the place the climate was nice the
environment was nice i kind of liked the
area
um it seemed like uh you know silicon
valley was was
nothing really yet or very little yet at
that time
um but uh i just sort of seemed like a
nice place
and uh so i was like okay you know i'm
gonna see
you know if i can get a job at stanford
and it turned out that the
uh i was at that time doing a bunch of
particle physics must have been yeah it
must have been as early it must have
been like 1981 it can't have been too
much later than that
um and um so
the stanford linear accelerator center
which was a sort of particle physics lab
was
was keen to get me to go there in the
stanford physics department and so on
and then it was like but i'm also
interested in computer science and um
okay you know oh you know you should do
something with the computer science
department as well
so i remember i i went to lunch with the
computer science department and um
it's a whole bunch of people there and
you've got to remember this was a time
before the web
so you know i didn't know i didn't have
the list of who were all the people in
the
you know today if i'd been going to
visit that department i would have said
who are all the professors in that
department who are all these people
you know what what are their stories and
so on but in those days
that was not an easy thing to find out
and so you know i just showed up there i
and um uh showed up to lunch and there
were people like a guy called ed
feigenbaum who was much involved with
with artificial intelligence um at that
time and and a whole variety of other
people
um who i'm not not immediately
remembering but there was this one chap
this white head chat
you go around the table and people are
introducing themselves and so on
and he says my name is john smith
it's like okay it seemed implausible
you know that's a to people at least
from the uk
the name john smith is kind of the john
doe of the us it's kind of the generic
name
and it's like okay you know seemed
unlikely but
i don't know uh you know and um
uh that kind of made it much more
difficult to have a conversation because
i didn't know who this person was and it
was kind of like okay what um
oh and that's right i think people said
a little bit about what they did and
they just sort of said i'm john smith
and that was
that was it i think that may have been
the first time i actually met john
mccarthy in person uh john smith was
john mccarthy needless to say
so a bit prickly um and um
i think uh um i had a
oh all kinds of subsequent interactions
with john mccarthy i think um
when i first started working on cellular
automata and on
simple programs that can do complicated
things
i i must have had been having sort of a
continuing interactions with john
mccarthy at that time that was probably
1983 1980
yeah 1983-ish anyway i sent john
mccarthy a copy of this
really short paper like three-page paper
that i've written about this stuff
summarizing what was going on he sent me
back this
i don't know how long it was you know
eight-page typed
letter about why my three-page paper was
nonsense
and um uh you know it was it was
not a particularly well-reasoned piece
but it was was basically
look we know a touring machine can in
principle
do anything so why is it news that a
simple cellular automaton program
can do complicated things well the
reason it's news is because we know that
we knew that in principle a sufficiently
complicated turing machine
could do anything you want with
sufficiently complicated programming
the news was that a a very simple
program a kind of turing machine that
you might pick at random or a cellular
automaton
that you might pick at random with a
very simple initial condition with very
simple programming would do something
complicated
that was news and um uh joe mccarthy was
was uh i was oh he didn't think that was
interesting
i don't remember i i'm someday i'm going
to put a lot of these archival materials
that i have on the web
um there's a lot of interesting letters
from lots lots of people but that's some
and i haven't looked at that letter in
in decades probably so
so i i can't tell you in in tremendous
detail what it contained
but um i remember um
you know i i don't really know uh you
know the personal history of john
mccarthy i think he
he um uh he had been at mit then he was
at dartmouth
um then he went to stanford pretty early
in the history of the stanford computer
science department
um and uh i think he had some
some some sort of personal misfortunes
and things
um which people say uh made him a bit
more prickly than he had been previously
um but uh i think the um
um uh you know certainly my
my interactions with him certainly uh i
remember
my new kind of science book i had a
variety of interactions with john
mccarthy
and it was
with a definite flavor from my side of
why don't you actually
read what it says rather than thinking
that you know what it says because i
don't think you know what it says
because it's actually surprising um
but anyway it um uh and i think um
uh so but that was uh i i have to say i
was very impressed i looked again
recently at john mccarthy's 1959 uh
paper about
lisp um the uh um
uh the the the thing that um uh
and you know it's a very good clean
paper um
anyway the the more a little bit more
about lisp i can tell you a few more
formula stories about lisp um the uh
back in the beginning of the 1980s
people are very keen to see you know
could we really make
lisp run fast and so one of the things
that happened was that there were
uh people say well let's just implement
lesbian hardware
and so there were two companies uh that
spun out of mit
mit was sort of a big the big lisp place
um and along with stanford i guess
but mit some somehow had more energy
around this
um and so there were two companies that
were started
uh that time uh one company called list
machines incorporated lmi and one
company called symbolics
and these both had some kind of license
to various technology from the mit
lab for computer science um to um or
maybe the ai lab
i think more likely the ai lab to go and
build these hardware list machines
um actually that was a um it was a time
when
when sort of the the early days of um
uh of kind of sort of the interaction
between
you know is software a thing that gets
paid for
by people who use it or a software a
thing that gets paid for some other way
and how that all worked and i know um
uh richard stallman was
um uh was somehow was a was a person who
was was
around at the ai lab and working on
things like emacs and so on
um and i think that the um uh the thing
that
um um was
uh uh the
one of the things that happened was as
these companies were getting formed
it was kind of the schism of where
people wouldn't go going to go to this
company and they thought they might get
rich and
going to go this company and richard
stolen was kind of left out of the whole
thing and
he was all upset and i think that was a
part of the motivation for for the whole
you know free software you know let's
just um
uh you know these these companies be
damned type thing
but um in any case the the um as it
turned out um
uh symbolics eventually went public i
think
yeah i remember that that um and there
were a bunch of people who
were sort of the the early list packers
who um you know all got had a little bit
of stock in in symbolics and did well
from it
um i think i i actually just recently
just a few days ago
i i was um i happened to be giving a
talk at mit
and um i was for quite different reasons
looking for something
else and and chanced upon the stuff
about mit and found this
actually a printout of a um
uh of a uh me logging into the mit
mc computer system in 1980 um through
the
uh what was then um the opponent now you
know the internet
um and it was kind of fun because there
was a little bit of email that was there
and i
i was obviously i need to send that to a
friend of mine with whom with whom i was
having an email correspondence at that
time and and point out that we really
were early adopters of email back in
back in 1980 and actually
all the way back to 1976 or so but any
case i
i found along with that i found an
interesting piece of email that i
exchanged with a person called
joel moses who had been um uh i don't
know if he's still around but
um i was a long time mit person
became a uh sort of senior administrator
i think at mit
but have been um much involved with the
creation of this thing called maxima
which was a lisp-based
mathematical computation system um but
in any case the um
this piece of mail was about what would
happen to maxima
and was it going to be a kind of free
system
a node joel moses said no no no we're
going to charge at least 10
000 a year um to people who who want to
use it and
and so on so it's sort of interesting to
see that as a as a thing emerging at
that time
well anyway the the um so uh
the the list machine companies came and
actually they built some very nice stuff
i didn't ever use their their technology
very much
um but uh it was a it was an interesting
uh kind of approach where sort of the
whole operating system
was was written in lisp it's kind of
thing that would be like writing
sort of everything like i try to exist
mostly more from language today
it's sort of the same story as the list
machines existing sort of lisp all the
way down so to speak
um but uh you know one of the things
that sort of happened to lisp was the
things like common lisp which became a a
very very very complicated system
and it kind of didn't you know in in
what we've done with wolfram language
uh there's kind of been a a sort of a an
approach to kind of um
uh dealing with uh dealing with sort of
the complexity of the language and the
and the scope and thinking about it as a
language to describe the world
whereas i think commonly just became
more complicated as a as a pure
programming language
and and people would probably say that
it had become way too complicated and
possibly unimplementably complicated
but that was that was sort of a bit of
the story of of lisp
um let's see okay let me look at a few
um
oh boy all kinds of there's a question
how is emacs related to lisp
um well it uses uh
an underlying kind of lisp like um
uh you know it has a it has a a lisp as
it's sort of
underlying it's very very advanced
really it's a
emax was a richard stallman production i
mean i should say i think this is no
longer
uh a secret but um long ago
uh there was outfit called the macarthur
foundation uh who were kind enough to
give me one of their sort of uh
uh they used to be called prize
fellowships i think but but one of the
you know fellowships back when they were
first giving these things out in 1981
and so they would always ask you know
can you suggest other people who should
get these things
and um uh one of the people i suggested
long long long time ago was richard
stallman thinking about the kind of the
gnu c compiler and emacs and so on and
so on and so on
it was kind of kind of interesting for
me because because yep they you know he
got he got this thing
and um uh which i thought was was great
and then then subsequently he really got
very big on the whole free software
thing
and i would meet him and he would be
like you know this stuff you're doing is
terrible you should be giving everything
away and that's the only way to make
progress and so on and
i have to say i said to him at that time
you know i'm not sure how it's going to
end with you saying you're just going to
give everything away
you know i'm not sure that's really
going to work out i don't think that's a
sustainable model
that will lead to sort of happiness of
everybody and in in more recent years i
i run into him and i i say so so what
happened with linux
and he's like oh that's so terrible they
took gnu they took everything i done
and i was like but didn't you say it was
it was free for the taking and so on and
he's like
yes but not in that way etc etc etc etc
etc
so it's it's one of these a little bit
for me it's one of these a little bit i
told you so but actually i
a couple few years ago now i i am uh the
thing i
i told you about about suggesting him
was is is definitely not
uh uh a secret because i happen to be at
some
event where the person who's now running
that program
and i was talking to that person and
richard storman walks up
and i uh somehow this came up and i i
just
you know explained this piece of history
right then right there
so that's the first richard stoneman had
heard of it and and um
uh so i think it's it's now uh an out in
the open kind of um
uh kind of fact but um uh it's it's kind
of a
a um uh um it's one of those interesting
interesting dynamics of um uh you know
uh the the people people don't
necessarily like you or hate you for the
right reasons so to speak
in any case um
let's see uh it was a question about
some
it's a question from colin fields do i
know line of store valves i do not know
line of store valves i know a lot of
people
in the in the software industry i do not
personally know linus
um the uh
let's see questions here oh my gosh so
many questions
let me let me just uh talk about ones
that are somehow
um uh
related to what i was just talking about
um
okay there's some questions from mikhail
here um
there's a comment uh that
on lex friedman's podcast some someone
was talking about
joshua luddenburg in the 1960s using ai
ideas to help nasa identify molecules
related alien life i suspect that was
part of the whole uh sort of dendral
um story of uh identifying and
and this kind of idea of you know
chemistry as as they're improving
and so on which is something which i
think is is uh it's time to bring that
back um
let's see questions here about um
um um
okay um
there's a comment here that uh from
pomenities that
nasa became interested in sanskrit as a
programming language i did not know that
that's cute
um the uh uh
okay well let's see oh gosh so many
questions here
um there's a question from mikhail about
um
what are the contributions of marvin
minsky to ai i knew marvin pretty well
for for many years actually um i i even
wrote something about him
when he died so if if you're interested
in more details that i perhaps won't
remember
right now i i refer you to that
um it's also in this book called idea
makers that i
that i put out about historical
biography um
well marvin so i mean
marvin was sort of uh uh
you know he he had wanted to study
neural nets
from an early stage but he kind of got
into doing
you know he did his phd at princeton in
in
fairly traditional math i think he had
wanted to do kind of neural net
math but nobody had let him do that um
and so
you know and he even started building
you know hardware neural neti type
things
um in the 1950s uh trying to explore
these kinds of things
um he ended up uh you know
one of his contributions to the neural
net field was this book that he wrote
with seymour pappert
simon pappert is particularly well known
as being the creator of the logo
programming language yes i also knew
simon pappert
though not as well as i knew marvin um
and uh
uh the um uh but anyway
they wrote this book called perceptrons
which was kind of which kind of killed
perceptrons
and it kind of killed neural networks
actually because what they did was they
showed
that in a sense perceptrons that have
been invented by this guy frank
rosenblatt
and were sort of a a one-layer neural
net in modern terms
um that this these perceptrons could be
represented could
in quite simple mathematical terms um
they're sort of just finding nearest
neighbors in this kind of linear way
and so in a sense that book showed
a one-level neural network couldn't do
anything interesting it was just doing
the simple mathematical operation
well as is so often the case people
ignored the little footnote that said
one level neural nets and for many years
it was like neural nets can't do
anything interesting
marvin and seymour proved that neural
nets can't do anything interesting
and and that was it was not until the
1980-ish time frame
the whole sort of parallel distributed
programming and like my friend terry
sanofsky and people like jeff hinton
and and other people i've sort of
brought back the idea
of um of neural nets and said well
actually these these multi-level neural
nets
which have been much more difficult to
train perceptrons are rather easy to
train
um we should really look at these and
these might be interesting but
um that was and at that time um uh well
there were uh they still didn't really
get started the whole sort of deep
learning
you know deep neural net type thing
didn't really get started until
until around 2011 um but it had been
sort of slowly smoldering
from the 1980s on having been originated
way back in 1943 by mcculloch and pitts
but um so one of marvin's contributions
which he always was rather unhappy about
that um that this had been its conc well
at least subsequently he was unhappy
about it
he didn't really i mean he was he was
around in the sort of the rebirth of the
neural net
uh uh you know interest in neural nets
but he didn't really engage in that i
think
um i don't try to remember if i ever
talked to him about that i'm sure i must
have done
but i don't think he was i don't think
he really engaged at that time
but um you know he had um
uh he was very much involved in um
kind of the uh you know having done the
neural net thing
and having written the perceptron's book
and having sort of oh this kind of
statistical ai machine learning thing
isn't going to work let's do more
symbolic ai
let's do more kind of ai that is a uh
is based on kind of um uh reasoning
and um sort of logic and things like
this
and he then had a sort of a series of
models for kind of
sort of a mixture of how the brain works
and how ai might work and
the theory of frames and a whole bunch
of theories
which i have to admit i i'm not
completely sure i ever completely
understood
um some of those theories led to
spin-offs like the whole
connection machine computer thing his
student danny hillis
uh ended up sort of let's make this in
hardware um
and that became a sort of a massively
parallel computer
which i can tell you many many stories
about that will be a separate topic
um but uh that was that was another kind
of
a spin-off of sort of marvin's theory of
mind type thing
sort of computational a possible
computational theory of mind
you know i i okay i must tell a personal
story perhaps about marvin
um and this is where uh you know i i
still have to define my
my rules for for these historical
discussions but um
uh marvin's daughter margaret is
somebody i've known for many many years
um and uh this must have been
1984 or 1985.
uh margaret was spending the summer in
japan uh
i was living in princeton at the time
and i was going to spend part of the
summer in boston
and so i i sublet margaret's apartment
from
margaret for you know a couple months or
whatever it was
okay so there's there's margaret's
apartment uh and
one of the features it had was a very
large number of plants
um and uh you know as a whole sort of
sort of
i don't know almost greenhouse full of
plants there it wasn't quite a
greenhouse but it was sort of a
a side part of the of the whole thing
was was this thing with all these plants
and so i'm i'm like okay you know i try
and water your plants do they really
need you know how
what am i supposed to do with your
plants okay well you know you could
water them but anyway so i i'm doing
this
and i see these plants have um a little
white spots on them their leaves have
white spots on them so it's like what am
i going to do
about margaret's plants which i clearly
have some problem
but i'm not a you know not enough of a
the web didn't exist i couldn't go look
up white spots on
on this kind of plant um and uh
you know what am i gonna do so and
margaret was off in japan and
etc so so i call marvin and i say so
marvin you know
margaret's plants have white spots on
their leaves what should i do
marvin launches into this long probably
hour-long discussion
about um uh micro robots and the idea of
you know
we really should have these things that
are like um you know
flying micro robots that would go and
attack the little
parasites that are attacking the um uh
the plants and so on it was it was a
lovely conversation about sort of the
future
of micro robots and so on and um at the
end of this whole long discussion
i'm like okay marvin but what should i
actually do about margaret's plants
he said well you should talk to my wife
gloria um and so
she had some practical thing to say
which i don't remember but that was a
that was a very typical marvin
interaction
i mean i actually i'm i'm i'm now
remembering i think probably the first
time i met marvin
must have been 1978
9 something like that
marvin came to visit dick fineman
who i knew quite well at that time
i was at caltech he was at caltech i we
were trying to do some work together
um must have been oh gosh
uh well probably 1980 i would guess this
happened so anyway so marvin
uh what was the what was the whole
detail of this i i
the thing that sticks in my mind is um
uh we're driving through pasadena
uh marvin dick fineman myself and um i
kind of think marvin was driving and um
i kind of think that marvin was
launching into this
long description about self about
autonomous driving
and self-driving cars and what will be
involved in doing them
and look at how complex it is to figure
out you know
uh the rules for what to do at this
intersection that intersection
um and i i have this i have this
recollection i'm i'm this is a very long
time i haven't thought about it i think
i might have written about this in the
in the piece i wrote about marvin
um but uh uh the i have this
recollection of being
really a bit a bit terrified by the
actual driving that was going on
um and uh with this whole but with this
whole discussion of you know but ais
will be able to drive
real soon now that was 1980. i think
we're still far away from self-driving
cars that can deal with the complexities
even that we were seeing in some of the
uh some of the situations there
but anyway so marvin uh marvin was was
very much of a
a a thinker far into the future about
all these kinds of things i think that
in terms of
of his actual concrete models of about
ai and so on
i you know i'm not sure what to say
about that because
in um uh uh
you know i remember he wrote a book um
called society of mind
and he gave me a copy of this book um
before it came out it was must have been
mid-1980s
and it was originally he was going to
write that book in in poetry
um i think many people i i was certainly
one of them said
that's really a crazy idea but as it was
it was kind of a one idea per page book
and and these ideas range from really
quite interesting and thought-provoking
to like
er whatever um type ideas
and i think marvin then wrote a book i
think was called the emotion machine
which he spent a lot of effort on
and i talked to him about that at some
length and i i tried to say sort of
what kind of a thing is this you know
are you kind of channeling something
like freud who had sort of a theory of
the mind and its operation
or are you channeling something that is
more like sort of a
a more mechanistic or more sort of
operationalizable
sort of ai kind of thing and and i think
he
it was kind of interesting to to hear
that um um
that sort of discussion of and i think
he he thought it was more like kind of a
freud
type story of this was a a kind of
explanatory framework for thinking about
emotions and so on and marvin was big on
these kind of theories
of um oh i don't know he was like you
know what is the cause of humor type
thing you know
why do people laugh how does that you
know what is the kind of
what is the mechanistic almost
darwin-like freud-like
uh form of explanation of what was going
on um
now you know that was sort of the later
years of marvin in the earlier years of
marvin
before i knew him in the 1960s and so on
one of the things he did he wrote a book
called computation finite and infinite
machines
it's a great book it's um was one of the
first sort of clear descriptions of you
know
turing machines tag systems this that
and the other
it didn't mention combinators it didn't
mention some of my other favorite
systems didn't mention cellular automata
but it was um it was a system it was a
book that um
kind of really sat down in a clear way
sort of some of these early models of
computation and how they were related
and so on
and i think partly in connection with
that book marvin
um uh tried to find what was the
simplest universal turing machine
and he found this touring machine with
um uh
four colors on its tape and seven uh
seven
uh head states and that he found that in
maybe 1962 or so
partly in connection with this book um
and
he also told me he had studied the
turing machines with two head states and
two colors on that tape there 4096 of
those
and he'd looked at them and in fact i
think he says in the book that you can
examine their behavior
but you wouldn't want to it's too
tedious and so on and i have to say it's
kind of funny because just in the last
few days i've been looking at
things related to turing machines and
those i've been you know nowadays it's
just an instant you know involvement
language there's a function called
turing machine
and it literally you just you know boom
you can get the behavior of all those
4096 touring machines and you can verify
what marvin also discovered around 1960
or so
um that yes none of them can do anything
terribly interesting and none of them
can be universal
but marvin at that point sort of said
well it's too complicated to find you
know to try and
explore what touring machines do by any
kind of experimental means
and and then he found by by sort of
theoretical work
this 47 turing machine that was
universal well for many many many years
that was the simplest universal turing
machine
actually until well i i kind of found a
turing machine in the mid 1990s
that i guessed might be universal that
had um
has two head states and three colors on
its tape i didn't know whether it was
universal we put up this uh
prize it was uh what was it 25 000
prize we put up in 2007 for somebody who
could prove or disprove
that this turing machine is universal
and a young chap was a then young chap
named alex smith in england um who was a
um
at that time a student studying uh
computers into into kind of um
uh uh exotic programming languages and
so on
thinkers now um uh works on compilers
and so on um
anyway he he he proved that that turing
machine is actually universal
and i think marvin was a bit
disappointed when um uh when his
his uh his record for the 47 turing
machine
was finally broken after i can't do the
math
after um uh whatever it was nearly 50
years or something
um by this by what is now we now know as
the minimal
universal turing machine uh marvin was
on the the kind of the that i i
i got him to be on our prize committee
to kind of assess
potential solutions to this this project
so so um
he was he was aware of that but but um
uh but but i thought you know marvin's
early work on sort of the theory of
computation was really
uh was really very strong and very very
sort of clear
his work on on sort of ai and these kind
of models of ai
it became a little bit unclear kind of
what the point was what kind of a thing
was being deduced
and as i said i think it should more be
thought of in a kind of darwin freud
type way
than in the way that one really thinks
uh usually as of sort of
computational science mathematical
science operating
but you know marvin was always um oh i
don't know he was he was um
he was very big on the the let's try and
think about things in a different way
uh even if it's kind of weird like i
remember one time
then not not so many years before he
died i was at his house
and um he says to me um
what would you conclude if the sun
didn't come up tomorrow
and it's like um uh you know well marvin
let's take apart that question and you
know what
what kind of a thing do we mean by that
and you know would we conclude there was
some bizarre atmospheric phenomenon that
was
uh you know blocking out the sun or did
we conclude that the earth had stopped
and so on but it was a it was a funny
kind of question a funny kind of uh
funny kind of construction um but but
marvin liked those kinds of things and i
think
um marvin was also very much into
the um well all of these kind of thought
experiment type questions and
for example he he was interested in
physics he never
really i mean he never really i think
knew that much about sort of the 20th
century developments in physics
of you know quantum field theory in
general and things like that but he was
he was interested in physics and you
know there was a time
in the 1960s when it just looked like
you know the computing paradigm what we
now believe actually
that the computing paradigm is just
going to solve everything but it looked
like that was really close at hand
and so marvin and others were like well
you know maybe we can solve physics too
and i think he wrote a little paper
called nature abhors a vacuum
that was um about uh kind of there must
be you know photons must be
it's kind of like the ether that people
have believed back in the
in the time of of maxwell and so on for
for the the you know the luminiferous
ether
in which light waves will be carried as
sound waves are carried in air type
thing
and marvin was like but computation must
let that be
something that you know if we if we
think about the world computationally
there must be similar kinds of things
going on and there was a certain amount
of
of weirdness with uh maybe marvin wasn't
perhaps involved with this but but um
um uh my friend ed fredkin is always is
always bringing this story up as a
as an example of how people don't
understand things that
um uh people are saying well look if the
universe is computational what about the
round off error
because after all we know that you know
physics involves numbers and
and numbers with certain precision and
what about you know can't we detect the
round-off error well
at some level that's a that's a correct
thing to ask you know can't we see the
the granularity of space-time for
example if space-time is granular
but it's not really the right thing to
talk about it as a round-off error
that's really a
a different kind of concept that comes
once you have numbers and computers and
you're sort of casting those numbers
into digital form
but um yeah i could probably tell you a
lot more a lot more things about marvin
i i think that um
uh for me sometimes um
marvin was a little frustrating i mean i
always enjoyed him because he was always
a
a person who would just have the wildest
things to say
and um you know he has had this house
and um
uh in brookline and uh just across the
river from cambridge
um and um he uh it was a house
full of just the most amazing stuff um
and i think um uh unfortunately i i well
particularly his wife was involved just
collected uh
an awful lot of stuff but to the point
where there was this terrible disaster
when a ceiling finally collapsed
and now the house is quite cleared up um
the uh but but um
uh you know that stuff included things
like you know
the early apple stock certificates that
were found you know
stuffed somewhere that um uh uh
i think i i think i have that right um
might be a different company but i think
i think that's some
uh but just uh just a a a wonderfully
eccentric kind of uh
setup anyway um
let's see the questions here about um
uh from juan about scheme
well scheme was was um uh
um uh really the the
jerry sussman who was a student of
marvin's was i think the main person
behind scheme
which is sort of a derivative of lisp i
i don't know much about it i mean i know
jerry sussman though not
no i haven't seen him in years actually
um
he uh um yeah i really i really have
little to say about that unfortunately
um it um uh
i mean jerry sussman went on in addition
to doing scheme
did some interesting projects like this
kind of digital orare
trying to compute the motions of planets
for long periods of time to find out
about stability of the solar system
all sorts of fun things like that um
let's see all right let's let's
address something different here um
okay there's a funky question for from
mikhail why did ludwig boltzmann
commit suicide well
um you know that's always unfortunately
that that's that's always more of an
internal psychological question than
anything else but
but um i'll tell you the kind of the
folk story and i'll tell you what i know
about the real story
um so first thing literary boltzmann was
a
german physicist in the um
well mid to later 1800s
and uh he was most famous for
introducing the concept of entropy
as a as a counting of state for relating
entropy to the counting of microscopic
states and things like gases
and that's what led to boltzmann's
constant lowercase k
that's the constant of proportionality
between temperature and energy
um uh that that um
uh for for for
you know degrees of freedom like motions
of gas emotions and molecules
and gases and so on but but boltzmann
um was uh was really an early person in
the development of statistical mechanics
and one of the things that is often said
kind of the folk story
is that boltzmann never managed to
convince people
about his work on statistical mechanics
and that
made him depressed and so he committed
suicide i think
the the truth is more complicated i
think he had some nasty medical
condition
that um uh you know really
uh impacted his quality of life and and
i think he was um
uh you know that that was probably a
another big factor
you know i found it fun that to realize
that you know
the way the the times line up you know
the late boltzmann was the early
university of california in berkeley
and the the you know the late boltzmann
with all these pictures you see of him
with a big bushy beard looking like the
the
quintessential kind of 1800s german
professor
actually he spent some time in
california you know the place that
hadn't had a gold rush too much earlier
um kind of uh at the new university of
california in berkeley and i kind of
wonder what that
was like at that time and and what his
interaction i kind of have this image
of him as the quintessential kind of um
uh classic
you know kind of stiff german uh you
know professor of the 1800s
and so i kind of wonder what that was
like in the you know going to the wild
west so to speak of of the um
of the late 1800s at uc berkeley i don't
really know
um but any case the the um uh you know
the big thing that boltzmann um um
there were uh boltzmann had this
idea that entropy which was a thing that
had been observed as a
have been used by people thinking about
some things like heat engines and
questions in chemistry
was sort of a property of materials that
you could attribute a certain entropy to
them
um that was different from their energy
it was another kind of quality
and what boltzmann uh said was um
that you could you could associate
entropy
as being sort of a counting of the
number of microscopic possible states of
molecules
consistent with uh the the macroscopic
observations of the material
now of course at that time molecules
were kind of a new thing i mean it was
only
1840s 1850s you know people discovered
oh when was brownian motion maybe
1830s 1840s uh brownian motion was one
thing and then there was the
dalton's work a little bit earlier than
that on kind of the
the the the numbers that occurred in
chemistry and how you know there were
two of this and three of that and you
could account for certain chemical
reactions that way and that kind of gave
this indication
that there were really discrete
atom-like things but but atoms
people didn't really know that mata was
made of atoms um and that was sort of a
somewhat new thing in boltzmann's time
and i think that um in um uh
um uh yeah and and so so that was to
think about you know what was the
macroscopic consequence
of the thing the fact that things were
made of atoms was an interesting thing
i think one piece of history that i do
recall is this
this strange kind of chain of history in
which
in a sense boltzmann uh thought about
um his uh so so uh i think this dates um
there's some date markers here so eight
um
1859 was the publication assuming i
don't get these dates wrong i'm dates
from memory are always a little bit
scary but was the publication of
darwin's origin of species
and one of the things was that boltzmann
actually thought about it sort of
evolution of molecules evolution of the
configurations of molecules
as being something that he was sort of
deriving in some sense
from not not in a mathematical sense but
in a conceptual sense
from kind of darwin's they're all these
little individual organisms
and they're struggling for life and so
on and that was and they have some
aggregate effect that might be
the whole the development of life on
earth and i find it kind of interesting
because darwin on the other hand
was somewhat channeling malthus who had
been talking about kind of economic
kinds of questions
um you know in his sort of struggle for
life he was kind of channeling
you know malthus's ideas about uh
you know how how economic systems work
and so it's kind of a funny chain
because it went in a sense the
the flow of ideas went from economics
to biology to physics which is kind of
the exact opposite of the way that one
might
think in more modern times that things
should flow so i think it's sort of
interesting that was the way the
intuition went
um but anyway boltzmann uh one of the
things that he wanted to show
was the second law of thermodynamics had
been that was kind of a thing of the
1860s or so
that um people had observed this entropy
tends to increase
and um uh people like kelvin had been in
that picture
um was the um
oh my gosh rumford is that right am i
remembering correctly
um people people uh i think khan no
might have been and sadi khano might
have been involved in that also
the the sort of the realization that
yeah in fact
conor must have been involved because
because one statement of the second law
of thermodynamics is heat doesn't
spontaneously flow from a hotter body to
a colder body
and that relates much to kind of cono's
sort of engineering style
heat engine treatment of thermodynamics
but anyway so
so there was a question of why is it the
case that heat doesn't flow from a
hotter body to a colder body
why is it the case that things you know
mechanical motion
degrades into heat things tend to end up
going to the situation where there's
heat and not systematic mechanical work
this was a story of the increase of
entropy and that was the thing that
boltzmann set out to explain
uh from his microscopic theory of
molecules
well so he made up this thing called the
boltzmann equation
still used today which is an equation
that describes with differential
equations
describes the microscopic uh you know
collisions between molecules and the
consequences of collisions between
molecules
and describes the kind of distribution
of molecules that you get
from a from a sequence of collisions
between them and so
what um uh he then came up with um
uh with this boltzmann equation and from
that he proved this thing called
boltzmann's h theorem
and boltzmann's h theorem basically says
that this quantity called h
which is now actually i think it's minus
the quantity we now call
entropy s um the uh
um it um
uh that that basically the upshot is
this theorem claimed to prove that
entropy increases with time
okay the problem is that underlying that
is a model for molecules bouncing around
that is completely reversible in time
so just as you can run boltzmann's htm
and say entropy increases in time
so you can also run it and say entropy
decreases in time and people pointed
this out
it was called the reversibility
objection i think los schmitt was
responsible for pointing that out if i'm
not mistaken
um but people were like you know
professor boltzmann this cannot possibly
be correct
you know it goes the other way et cetera
et cetera et cetera and i don't know if
boltzmann ever really understood what
was going on there
um i think people you know would say so
your whole theory of entropy
coming from microscopic molecules can't
be right et cetera et cetera et cetera
and people didn't really believe it um
and uh you know in the end
the real issue is that that what he was
assuming is the so-called molecular
chaos assumption
that molecules are uncorrelated before
they collide but after they collide
they get correlations and so when you
run things backwards you have to say
well they're uncorrelated
in future and then then rather than
they're uncorrelated in the past and
that's sort of
why you break out of that that idea so i
think the the the thing that
um uh so anyway i i think boltzmann
kind of sadly went to his grave not
really understanding sort of the
resolution of questions like that and
and famously his tombstone has um
i think it says s equals k log omega
but that doesn't jive with the fact that
there's an h that he defines or maybe it
was called
s by that time but anyway it was it was
um
uh you know it's that's
that was his story is this relationship
between
entropy and this microscopic uh
character of things
i mean that that relationship that idea
of statistical mechanics
um this idea that you can kind of get
aggregate properties of things
from the sort of the aggregate of lots
of discrete molecules bouncing around
um you know james clerk maxwell uh
famously derived the maxwell
distribution
of velocities and gases um that was a
thing that he did he did that actually
as a
um as part of a kind of a school
assignment
well kind of i think he was competing
for some essay competition
that was supposed to be about um the the
moon the the
the rings of saturn and so somehow
uh the the young jamie maxwell
uh thought look i'm doing this exercise
about the rings of saturn but i've got
to do some more basic science to figure
that out
and then he figured that the maxwell
boltzmann distribution a molecule of
distribution of
velocities of of molecules and a gas and
and then subsequently
um by the night and by 1900 or so i
actually only recently learned this
uh people like david hilbert who was
sort of a a big figure in
in pure mathematics was very very very
interested in this whole question of
statistical mechanics
this question of how microscopic uh
atomic processes
could become this macroscopic phenomenon
of things like the flow of fluids
continuous flow of fluids and so on i
find it interesting he spent about 20
years working on that
before coming back to working on
foundations of mathematics and so on
and you know he didn't really solve
those problems um turns out those
problems are really front and center in
the
in the work we're doing on fundamental
theory of physics now and and the
problem he was trying to solve of could
you understand
things like space as discrete and with
some kind of continuum limit that's
that's the exact story of what we're
trying to solve now it's a it's a shame
that david hilbert didn't have um
uh you know didn't have the sort of
computational paradigm we have today
i mean strangely as i sort of uh really
studied um last month um
in connection with mos the centenary of
moses schoenfinkel on the invention of
combinators
david hilbert had computation right
under his nose
he went to the talk almost certainly on
december 7th 1920
in which moses schoenfinkel introduced
combinators which were the first sort of
really concrete formal version of
computation as we know it today
but all those connections weren't made
as as usually these things aren't
and it took another oh many many many
decades
before that that really became clear but
then in statistical mechanics the next
you know big
big figure was um josiah willard gibbs
who was an early american physicist um
worked at yale
um and uh uh he was the person who um
must have been 1910s 1920s things like
that was really a person who sort of
put more serious mathematical structure
into thinking about thermodynamics and
things like gibbs ensembles and the
the gibbs rule and all these other kinds
of things and and he really tried to
sort of put the math into thermodynamics
anyway uh let's see
ah okay uh fact check here
just uh boltzmann's tombstone says s
equals k
log w okay so the w got uh capital w so
i think subsequently it was a capital
omega was was used for that
um
um
okay there's a few so many interesting
questions there i'm sorry i i'm
having a hard time and and by the way
feel free to ask about more detailed
questions about people and
um uh you know i've i've i've had the
good fortune over the last probably 50
years to to meet
um almost 50 years i've been sort of
somehow doing science-y kinds of things
to meet a good cross-section
of um uh kind of people who've been
doing science that
impinges on kinds of things i've been
interested in at least and and i
certainly am
i can try and give you my impressions of
some of these people um that might might
be of interest
um the uh
well there's a question from paul
manates if you had to choose only one
country's mathematics
you will be allowed to use which one
would it be england france or germany
oh boy i mean the traditions of of
mathematics
in past centuries between different
countries um
are are very um uh
well we're sort of different although
you know it's funny because
for example the modern notation of
mathematics is completely international
you know you don't see i mean people
write you know
they it's it's very rare that you the
the note the pure notation
is is sort of international sometimes in
like russian papers and things you'll
see
something like determine for debt you
might see a different a different word
for that little fragment there
um and you know the the origination of
of the international
version of mathematical notation was in
a sense by design i mean people like
gottfried
uh leibniz in the in the late 1600s
who was inventing some of this notation
you know the d by d whatever the
integral sign all those kinds of things
well
well leibniz's inventions he was you
know his day job was sort of being a
diplomat
type uh or at least a back room you know
study the facts diplomats kind
kind of person um the uh a staffer i
suppose one might say in modern times
although i think he did do some
frontline diplomacy he's more like a
courtier courtier-staffer type
person but anyway he um
he really wanted to use mathematical
notation as a way to have a
an internationalized way of
communicating mathematical ideas
i mean i think he he was living at a
time when latin which had been
for for 1500 years or at least a
thousand years
kind of the language of scholarship the
language of of learning
was beginning to sort of break up into
people were using english they were
using german they were using french
as sort of uh the language of
scholarship as an alternative
and so you know he was sort of hoping
that by by having and it was successful
by having this mathematical notation he
could have this kind of international
standard
for how mathematics would be described
but i think um
uh the actual traditions of these
different countries
ended up being a bit different i mean
you know for example in calculus
there was kind of the continental
tradition that followed leibniz
and the british tradition that followed
newton
and newton had a very geometrical view
of calculus leibniz has a very
sort of algebraic view of calculus
newton had this whole notion of fluxions
um and uh you know x dot and so on that
was the whole newton notation
i would say that newton was not as
notationally sophisticated as leibniz
didn't really
pay so much attention to notation he was
much more you know
doing things in the style of euclid
proving sort of geometrical style proofs
and so
on i remember newton had various kinds
of um
um uh names for things like kineton i
think was one of his
names i'm trying to remember i remember
when i was a kid
i grew up in oxford england and i there
was a there was a road called kineton
road
and again it's a pity the web didn't
exist because i would have just typed it
in and i would have known all the story
and i'm sure one can immediately do that
um but i i said what what on earth was
this thing that's not a standard road
name
and it was apparently some some kind of
newton spin-off type thing although
newton was primarily a cambridge man um
the uh
um it's um um
i think um uh uh
you know so so i mean these these kind
of um um
uh you know the the different traditions
of different countries
uh you know what happened in france for
example
in the 1800s there was this much more
kind of
formal structured tradition um
uh as well um that was really much more
abstract and much more
you know a move towards abstraction and
move towards some
sort of precision and abstraction the
british tradition was much more of a
let's just hack it together and make the
math work
and and learn a bunch of tricks to you
know was a lot of you know the cambridge
wrangler you know mathematical wrangler
let's learn all these clever ways to do
integrals
and all these tricks for doing integrals
rather than let's find the sort of
abstract characterization
of what's going on in integrals and and
people like um
you know babbage famously was was like
you know let's reform the way that
cambridge mathematics works let's bring
in
some of this more abstract continental
stuff
i would say that the german tradition if
i were to characterize it might have
been a little bit more
i would say the french tradition was um
uh well definitely had a more
geometrical flavor the german tradition
had a more algebraic favor
people like grassman and so on were very
much into the sort of the
the formalization of algebra um whereas
the
the sort of i would say i mean there had
been people like galwa and france but
but i would say that in general there
was a little bit more of a
geometrical flavor to sort of the french
tradition and that led eventually to
people like poincare
which was sort of a a somewhat more
geometrical take on
on how things worked and the invention
of topology and so on
but i think that the um um and you know
it's also worth realizing as we look at
the history of those times
that there were things like the
three-body problem the gravitational
uh the problem of gravity between earth
moon and sun
that was a a big dominant problem of the
1800s that was like that was the
the holy grail of a lot of that
mathematics and a lot of things were
done
including even the invention of topology
was done sort of in the service of that
kind of idea
um i think it's uh you know people in
more
sort of supporting this more algebraic
style of things people like cantor
were working in germany inventing
trans-finite numbers towards the end of
the 1800s
people like fraga inventing kind of this
um
uh sort of math is built on logic more
sort of algebraic tradition stuff
um i noticed that parmenides mentions
russian mathematics
which certainly became uh significant in
the 20th century
i i'm um uh the the
the pre-20th century russian mathematics
i'm i
i mean i i i'm familiar only with some
small pieces like labor chefsky
and so on i i have the impression that
that really developed
uh in in the you know particularly in
the 20th century
um but i might i might be wrong about
that i i'm i'm um
uh i'm not sure um i mean i suppose i
suppose to people like oyler
who was kind of you know that's a
complicated case because euler was
was hanging out in koningsberg which was
in prussia
which is sort of poland-ish type area
but he was also
you know swiss prussian
russian he also spent time in the
russian uh court so that that may have
been a
uh sort of a a um um
euler famously has this this book what's
it called letters to a
that's letters to a russian princess
right i think that's its name
yeah which was uh um a uh so he was sort
of involved with those kinds of things
um let's see
oh boy this is a question from
lex a bit about about visual programming
languages i think that's probably not
for this live stream
let me let me uh talk about that in a
different um
and different place um are there
questions here about people
did i interact with jim watson or
francis crick
uh yes i i am uh
some good friends of mine were good
friends of francis cricks and i
i ran into quite quite a lot of times
uh jim watson i ran into only run into
only a few times
um i would say um uh the um
uh francis crick you know
was always i think the let me have a
crazy idea kind of guy
when i knew him he was uh really into
kind of um
brains he was at the salk institute at
that time in in san diego
um and he was really into kind of uh
things about brains and he had sort of
theories of sleep and so on
and he always he was coming up with all
these crazy theories you know
once upon a time in 1953 he had a crazy
theory that maybe
you know the dna molecule was storing
digital information about genetics
that crazy theory turned out to be right
um i think
i'm not sure that any subsequent francis
great theory
turned out to be right they were
interesting not necessarily right he had
theories about consciousness and
theories a lot of theories about how
brains work um
i mean jim watson i think has has um uh
was always very
um uh the times i interacted with him uh
very um uh quite a dogmatic fellow
about um uh you know with a very very
much uh
i would say in some ways a scientist
scientist of um
uh uh you know with a definite view of
of kind of
uh you know here's how science should
work and everybody who isn't a scientist
doesn't know what's going
on which i think sometimes led him
astray in in particular in areas of
public policy and so on
and i remember one oh gosh i
i mean i remember a a a a weird
interaction with jim watson about some
you know science versus religion
discussion which which made me not
um uh you know kind of made me feel that
that it's like
uh you know i i think you're just being
dogmatic you know it's not
you're not actually thinking about the
real issues it's it's more just this is
kind of
this is you know science as scientists
think it should be
and and sort of following that um um
um that idea i think um
uh i should should wrap up soon here but
but their questions um
uh oh i'm being corrected on the
on the oiler i thought that didn't sound
right euler's book was letters to a
german princess not russian so i i was
wrong there
um the i thought it didn't sound right
um
oh gosh there are questions here uh
there are a few of these and then we
should wrap up for today
um there's a question from solo about do
you apply monte carlo simulation
and then it might work uh you know
sometimes i sample things at random
uh usually i prefer to make to have a
system make its own randomness i have to
say
i did know nick metropolis um i guess
the
i guess the inventor of the metropolis
method uh for doing monte carlo sampling
and so on
he was uh worked at los alamos he'd been
one of the people who worked on the
manhattan project
and some some group of people from the
manhattan project kind of stayed on
at los alamos was one of them nick
metropolis was another
um and uh i knew these people in the in
the early 1980s when i
spent some time at los alamos national
lab um
and um uh let's see there's a question
here from
ezekiel uh did i ever meet conrad zuza
or study his work
okay i will tell you a little bit of um
um
um there's a comment here from
cap kapparin saying i ran into aaron
kluger max peretz
max perez was lovely erin klug just told
me
uh um cleaner get out okay used to clean
their offices
interesting okay um i i ran into max
parrot
somewhere and i also thought he was a
lovely fellow
um but uh about that i think he was
involved with the
the cambridge um uh the whole cambridge
crystallography crowd
um and i guess i i ran into some of
those people
if i'm not mistaken uh when i was a kid
i um i was a pretty young kid like like
11 maybe right 11 12 years old
something like that i i went to stay
with a friend of my parents who was an
academic in
in cambridge and um i uh
um went to um
uh uh somehow i was you know a science
kid so it's like
come and see the cool science things in
cambridge and so
two cool science things i i saw
uh one was at the crystallography
department of crystallography which
existed in cambridge at that time i
think it was probably
a spin-off of the bragg father and son
team who'd invented x-ray
crystallography but the
the cool thing for kids at that time was
they they had a piece of moon rock
and so you could kind of see the um and
they also had a scanning uh
um a an electron microscope um
and i even have somewhere uh somebody
there gave me you know as a science kid
they gave me this
photograph come out of the electron
microscope of a piece of that piece of
moon rock
which i i'm sure i still have the the
the photograph from the
the microscope at that time but but um
there were a bunch of crystallographers
some
uh duncan mckee i think was one of them
and a few others
um who i as a pretty little kid ran
into and another another site i remember
seeing in the in the cambridge um
you know tourist uh um uh
uh you know the cambridge um uh you know
11
12 year old whatever um must i think i
must have been 11
at that time yeah that's about sounds
about right um
the uh you know uh what does the 11 year
old science kid see around cambridge
the other thing to go see was um the
radio telescope
and um the um now maybe it was earlier
than that
i i'm forgetting maybe it was two
different trips but um anyway i see this
radio telescope and it was um a a kind
of um
i guess uh what would now be called a
synthetic aperture
telescope it was it was a instead of
being a big dish
like general bank had been um it was
this thing with just a bunch of separate
antennas
i'm out in this field i think of
mattingly road cambridge if i remember
correctly
anyway we go out there and it's a little
hut where there's this kind of um
uh place where there was the kind of
oscilloscopes and things and the
the whole sort of control thing and the
meta chat there called tony hewish
um who uh was was one of the uh as it
turns out
one of the creators of that radio
telescope and someplace i have some
you know i think it was um um uh
was the thing i'm not sure i did did
much of i did a lot less of it than i
should have done
was uh you know getting well no maybe i
didn't get a signature
i think i just have a diagram some
diagrams that that um
uh he drew for me about you know how
this how this telescope worked and so on
and um that telescope of course was the
telescope that had discovered pulsars
in 1968 and i'm kind of thinking this
was like 1969 or 1970 because it was
it was very soon after the discovery of
pulsars um
so uh but but but these things weren't
weren't famous then
and tony hewitt went on to win the nobel
prize and all this kind of stuff and
and um but uh um that was just the um
uh you know the who do you run into as a
kid i mean i remember the um
yeah there were all kinds of all kinds
of strange scientists that i ran into in
the kind of um
oxford cambridge circuit um as a as a
kid
and um i certainly developed an
impression of although probably not a
very deep one at the
at the at the ages i was then um i think
um
uh yeah anyway the the
the thing that um um i'm kind of
inclined to start talking about some
another scientist from those um
uh that oh we're going to come back to
carnegie in a moment and then we
probably wrap up but
but a scientist of that time who i who i
got to know quite well in later years
was
sydney brenner sydney brenner is sort of
in the news now because he's
he along with jim watson uh but sydney
brennan i think was the main one who
discovered messenger rna
and messenger rna is this thing
discovered in like 1961 i think
when he was in cambridge um and and
that's a messenger rna
is the thing that's being used to make
you know two of the two of the main
uh vaccines uh for the for that uh
hopefully will end this
pandemic that we're currently in so
messenger rna after
its it's 60-year run is now finally you
know in clinical practice
uh doing something interesting but but
sydney brenner was the was the
discoverer of that sydney was a a lovely
chap who who um
uh well i got to know in the last
probably 25
years or so a little bit more than that
maybe um
and he was always um he was a person
who was uh he kind of grew up in south
africa
and he'd almost become a doctor he he
actually
knew uh well see what papad also came
from south africa i think they knew each
other
in those um in those days but anyway
sydney brenner
um uh
was interested in computers and those
kinds of things were very early
early time and he'd been a at king's
college cambridge which was the same
place that turing was at
and i don't think
trying to think i don't i must have
asked anybody
this i'm not sure that he knew alan
turing
i know that sydney bennett was
responsible for getting kings college
to try and make a touring archive and i
i know i was i had i had always
remembered that in in
sarah turing turing's alan turing's
mother's biography of alan turing
she mentions towards the end of the book
that um
when alan turing towards the end of his
life did a bunch of which he died in
1954
um did a bunch of work on on um
biological morphogenesis
and one of the things that sarah turing
says is oh he was getting these letters
from all over the world from places as
far away as south africa
and i was once having dinner with sydney
brenner and we were talking about alan
turing
and and and he said oh yes he'd written
to alan turing
back when he was a student in south
africa um
and i was like oh that's the you know
by the way did you know that in sarah
turing's book she mentions
he got these letters and so that was the
letter that alan turing had received was
written by sydney brenner so but sydney
brenner
was always telling me you know you
should take all this computation stuff
you figured out you should apply it to
biology
and um you know there's there's
something to figure out about sort of
the computational foundations of biology
that is more than just the story of
genetics and dna
and uh you should really figure it out
and he was very um uh he's kind of a
very um uh very much of a
sort of evangelist of ideas and very
much of a um
if i hadn't had an awful lot of other
things to do he would have been very
convincing that uh
you know you should that should be your
research program i mean that was what he
had done with um
with things like the c elegans nematode
and its decoding and so on
uh a whole series of sort of great
sydney banner projects
um but i have to say that in very recent
times i think i might have some ideas
finally
that it's a shame i can't talk to cindy
brenner about anymore because he was a
person who
of of all sort of biologists i mean he
was always a bit frustrated that
biologists weren't
more kind of theory oriented one more
you know let's actually imagine a formal
theory and so on
okay let's um uh will come to uh khan
azusa
so khan azuza was a
german well technology person primarily
um and i exchanged letters with khan
azusa
towards the end of his life um in the
early 1980s
um because konadzuza had gotten
interested in cellular automata
and had had this kind of generalized
idea that maybe the universe was a
cellular automaton somehow
and actually in a sort of somewhat a
historical situation because
because he had kind of i think thought
about that in the 1940s
and um uh the um um
it's it's some uh but but ended up
writing about them in the 1980s
after he'd read a bunch of things that
i'd written about cellular automata
so it was kind of a confusing historical
sequence because
because you know there was sort of some
connection of things he was doing in the
1940s but then when i'm
seeing things he's doing in the 1980s
they're kind of after things i'd done
and so
it was kind of hard to untangle what was
happening when but in any case
the earlier history of khan azuza was
during the second world war uh conor
zouza constructed
a uh a mechanical computer that um
uh was perhaps the first binary
mechanical computer
and um it um uh this computer is a very
strange sort of story to it
uh many well must have been
six seven eight years ago i was in
germany
uh carne azuza was was dead by that time
but his son horst zuza
uh still alive and um uh
there was a at the german uh uh in
berlin
at the at the museum there at the
technical museum there
um there was a um a recreation
of um azusa's computer constructed in
world war ii
and um the i met horst zuzer at that
time
actually i had talked to um this must
have been
beginning of the 2000s there was a
a big kind of um you know a story of you
know did zuzia
invent the computer you know was it
you know touring von neumann
you know uh ecka uh munchley mutually um
uh kind of um atanasoff was it the
american tradition
was the computer really um uh um
uh really the the um um
uh was was the computer really a german
invention
so to speak and this was sort of a you
know obviously it's a matter of national
pride i think it's a little bit like
you know the television when i grew up
in england the television
was a british invention by a man called
baird uh you know after i've come to the
us it was an american invention by
sonoff and people i think um and uh i
think it's also a russian invention
and a french invention so these you know
these sort of larger scale technology
inventions it's it's not clear they
they really have one inventor but but
there was a period of time when there
was a big enthusiasm for
you know zuzo was the kind of um you
know the german inventor of the computer
so so it was sort of i i've been curious
about this history
and so i i um i had actually that's
right i
talked to hors souza on the phone um
uh probably early 2000s maybe 1990s
about this and i'd asked him a whole
bunch of things about you know
how much did konrad susan know about
turin
for example how much do you know about
these other kinds of things
horses didn't really know um
so anyway so eventually i'm in germany
i'm in at this berlin museum
and we're looking at this this
reproduction of the um
of the zuza's computer but built
apparently in 1944-ish time frame i
think
um and uh uh you know it was explained
that it wasn't
quite a precise reproduction but it was
sort of close and so on
and what was the you know were there any
plans well there was this one photograph
one photograph of the computer that was
sort of in situ
at konadzuza's parents house
from 1944 or so um
so i said so what happened to that
actual computer
what happened to the the physical
computer
well it was destroyed uh by allied
bombing in world war ii was told
actually i think i knew that before
and i was like okay uh you know
that's all well and good but you know
what happens to a metal computer
in a house that's bombed you know what
actually happens
did the house burn down did it you know
what was the actual
you know is there anything left and so
what then emerged was well actually
the computer was in the basement and um
you know it's like well okay so then we
we did a little bit of research i think
subsequent to that time
um of uh looking for data on allied
bombing runs
um and i think there was aerial
reconnaissance that that um
uh the british had of that of that area
and i think we were able to determine
um that uh you know yes there was that
house you could find a
a picture of it after after the bomb
fell on it
um and then the question was where
that's right when i was when i was at
this
um museum in berlin i the the key
question i asked was
where is that house the answer was it's
about five blocks from here
unfortunately i had a plane to catch and
i couldn't uh i couldn't stay and go and
go and explore that house
but um the um the thing that um
uh that we subsequently looked into this
and um
uh basically there was a whole question
of the the computer was in the basement
the house collapsed on top of the
computer what happened to the computer
and so i talked to some people who'd
have done urban archaeology and so on
asked them about some of the issues with
this uh things got a little bit more
complicated because there was also there
was an air raid shelter
that was nearby and maybe the computer
had been moved to the airaid shelter
maybe it hadn't zuza's parents actually
had two adjacent houses
one of them is still a house one of them
is has turned into kind of a an open
well was at that time an open space
oh by the way i should say that this
these houses were on the uh the
the western side of the berlin wall just
about one block from the berlin wall
on the western side actually in an area
that at that time
you know after uh world war ii and
the berlin wall went up was apparently a
kind of a very dumpy neighborhood though
i think it's now quite a chic
neighborhood
um but any case the the so the computer
that first computer from 1944 or
whatever uh
we still don't know what happened to it
and i i i had had this plan for a number
of years
to sort of mount an expedition and try
and you know find the
you know excavate the computer i i kind
of had this
uh um you know it's sort of a thing that
would be you know i had i'd ask people
how does it degrade over time it's made
of
steel and what you know what happens to
that in the soil et cetera et cetera et
cetera
basically there should still be a bunch
of computer left
um but hasn't been excavated and i think
there's been
you know it's sort of a question of of
um uh you know i'm sure it's in
you know might be in the basement of
somebody's house and it's like um uh you
know and
it's some then that that becomes a
complicated uh uh you know i asked my
urban archaeology friends
how does that all work and um you know
what do you do
when when it's kind of like an
excavation that's like this thing and uh
you know who owns it
all that kind of thing but but uh you
know that can all be worked out but i
think it's a
it's sort of a an interesting question
um
uh there's been a certain lack of
enthusiasm about excavating this
computer
among people uh like this museum and and
and uh
um and i i've kind of found that a shame
and one of the questions
is you know what is there about this
computer that might not be
a thing one would want to find in
today's world
and uh i kind of i think um
there's sort of a question well there
are a bunch of questions in fact i i
just recently learned from somebody
who had known zusa um uh
well i should say that the subsequent
history of zuza after that time zuza
started a a computer company
um in germany that made um uh initially
much more simple less sort of fancy
um kinds of computers as a practical i
think more tabulating machines
and then sort of advanced to more
elaborate computers
and there was you know the z1 the z2 you
know a series of zuza computers
um and i think that the um uh that
computer that that company
um uh well in the end didn't make it
but i think it lasted for quite a number
of years and i i was talking recently to
a chap called irwin angelo who's now in
his 90s who um was uh
works at eth in switzerland and uh had
been
described himself as the first
programmer of the first zusa computer
that was brought into switzerland and at
the time it was a
big deal to get a computer into
switzerland and it all had to be i don't
know almost smuggled in there and
and all kinds of all kinds of
complicated things had had to be done
but it's it's um so you know i think
that
um uh there's sort of a a
a whole swirling question of what was
the relationship between
sort of the german military effort and
what zuza was doing
and there are claims that um sort of the
the zuza
original zusa computer was funded as one
might imagine it would have been
um by the german air force interested in
in sort of aerodynamic calculations not
a silly thing to do
um but uh you know then there are all
kinds of questions about um
you know if you find the computer what
do you find stamped on the metal parts
of the computer and so on and
and all sorts of you know history that
um one has to decide whether one wants
to leave buried or not
um and i think that it's uh so so as it
is right now there's sort of a trailing
question
of what is the story of the of that
computer and you know how close is it to
the recreation that exists in the museum
what can we learn from this one
photograph that was taken of that
computer
what do we know about um about what
happened i i think that um
and what do we know about what zuza knew
about what people like turing had worked
on what was known um
you know in in the kind of german
military circles at that time
uh you know about um what was the amount
of diffusion of knowledge
uh you know there probably wasn't much
from from bletchley park and that whole
effort but
you know touring machines had been
pre-butchly parked
um although some you know many of the
people who were involved in that like
max newman and so on
um went on to have roles at bletchley
park and and and uh
you know it's hard to know what what
that what that mixing was
um it's sort of an interesting little
mysterious piece of history
all right i think i would um i should uh
wrap this up there's a question from
parmenides did i meet any rocket
scientists like venavon brown
i did not meet venevon brown i have to
say i i will um
oh gosh what was his name there was a
chap
who was one of the last remaining kind
of german rocket scientists from that
time
who strangely a young chap
who actually works at our company now um
but who i had
met throughout summer school had been
trying to get me involved with with some
initiative that was a space launch
initiative and
and this chap oh dear i can't remember
his name
but anyway just in a little bit of an
exotic story
because this chap had had some whole
different scheme for producing rockets
and so on and the only place he'd been
able to
to implement his scheme was in libya
as a um as a kind of um uh during the
qadhafi regime
and that was a place where he could
actually you know try out launching
rockets and things
and had done that for a while and when
that regime had fallen
he had ended up on some pacific island
and
so there was this rocket scientist uh
german rocket scientist um who had
sort of been in the von braun orbit and
then in the
in the libya orbit and you know just a
very strange collection of things
who'd wound up on this obscure you know
many aeroplane hops pacific island um
to uh operating a kind of a strange
resort
bed and breakfast type thing with a kind
of german rocket
scientist theming to it and i was i had
to say i
i tried to persuade my children that we
should take a visit trip there
but my children were unconvinced so
unfortunately i never did it and um
and and that chap died so that that um
so i can't tell a good story about that
all right we should wrap up here um
thanks for for joining us
um and thanks for lots of interesting
questions and there's a
sort of almost infinite collection of of
these kinds of
um historical uh uh things to talk about
um both in terms of uh somewhat
contemporaneous
some uh things that um
the people i've known and a much more
distant past
and i'm being reminded that actually we
have um
uh i'm i'm signed up gosh i must be
spending all my time doing these
livestream q a's
tomorrow we have another live stream q a
science and technology q a for kids and
others and some of those questions about
things like
visual programming language that were
asked here i'd be happy to try and
address there
i think in in subsequent weeks we're
going to be sort of separating some of
these uh
live streams in terms of days a little
bit more um this will be a series that
alternates between
these star planners to alternate between
history and science and technology
and uh business and innovation in
alternating weeks
so anyway thanks for thanks for joining
uh joining us
and uh